ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Android Developer
Lab+ for the 15th of November.
So we had a bit of a
break last week.
But we're back this week.
And it's been a mad busy week.
Android 4.2 is released.
Today's Hangout actually is all
based around Android 4.2
and what that means
to developers.
I'm Ankur Kotwal
and I'm joining
from the Sydney office.
And I'm joined by my
colleague Tony.
TONY CHAN: Hi everyone.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So Tony is joining
us from Hong Kong.
Well, let's get started with
this week's topic.
And it is Android 4.2 which
is also Jellybean.
So usually we start these
presentations with news.
But we have so much news that
the news became the topic for
the presentation itself.
All right.
So, Android 4.2 was released
a day before yesterday, for
those people that are
in Australia.
Time differences--
it could have been yesterday
for you, depending
on where you are.
So Android 4.2 is known
as Jellybean.
The Google managed Nexus devices
are starting to get
OTAs, or Over the Air updates.
So that includes the Google
provided Galaxy Nexuses, as
well as our current generation
of Nexus devices, the Nexus 4,
the Nexus 7, and the Nexus 10.
And for those of you that were
lucky enough to get through
with the pre-orders, you'll
get to try it out on your
Nexus 4s and your Nexus
10s very soon.
So that's really great.
And I'm sure there's
a lot of people
looking forward to that.
One thing I wanted to point out,
however, is that we have
this site where you can download
Nexus factory images.
So a lot of people actually use
this as a way to shortcut
the process and update sooner.
But the reason I wanted to point
it out is really for our
developer community.
Because one thing that I found
very useful to do, is
occasionally if I want to go in
and test my apps on older
releases of Android--
like let's say Gingerbread, or
even Ice Cream Sandwich--
you can go to this site and
download those factory images
and roll back your developer
devices.
So that's a good way to have a
single physical device but
test across multiple versions
of the Android platform.
So keep it in mind as part of
your developer's toolbox.
So Android 4.2--
it is called Jellybean.
Internally the version code
that we have is actually
called Jellybean MR1.
And it is API level 17.
Now the reason I'm mentioning
that we have a static define
for Jellybean MR1 is because you
may have some code in the
your apps that you want
to version gate.
Now typically we don't--
it's not necessarily good
practice to version gate your
code, but there are times
that you need to, right?
So if you're version gating
against this question, it's
android.os.build
.versioncodes.jellybeanmr1.
So one of the things that many
developers we've encouraged in
the past on ADL+ to do is to
update your apps so you're
targeting the latest
version of the SDK.
And if you go back to our first
ADL+, we talked about
the Android manifest XML file.
And really we dived quite
deep into that.
But one of the things we covered
was how you update
your apps so that you're
targeting the latest SDK.
And that is SDK version 17 So
in your user's SDK flag in
your Android manifest
file, you would just
change that to 17.
Now there are obviously good
reasons to do this.
Often we enable things in newer
versions of the SDK that
aren't available in
older versions.
So for example, if you're
running an old app and it's
not version 11 or upwards, then
you won't get the hollow
theme on devices that
support hollow.
So it's always a good idea,
and in general is good
practice, to always
target your SDK
to the latest version.
You should use the minimum SDK
version-- or min SDK version--
attribute to specify how far
back you want to support.
And of course there's a whole
bunch of development tools,
like Lint, that'll help protect
you from invoking code
that isn't supported on those
minimum SDK versions.
So you should go ahead into
that for Jellybean MR1.
But there are some caveats.
So in API 17, if you target
API 17, there are some
behavioral changes that we've
introduced to the platform.
So for example, content
providers, now when you
declare them, the default value
for the Android export
attribute is actually false.
So keep that in mind when you
update to these latest
versions of SDKs.
We occasionally make
changes like this.
And this is actually quite
well documented on
developer.android.com.
But here's a summary anyway.
The other thing we've done
now is when you request a
permission
access_coarse_location and you
don't specify
access_find_location, the
accuracy that you get back off
that location will always be
around the city block.
So in the past, even if you
didn't request find_locations,
there were times when
your accuracy
could have been higher.
The accuracy now will always be
coarse if you haven't asked
for find_locations.
And it's really just making
sure that we're consistent
with the permission
you're requesting.
The other gotchas or changes
that you should look out for
are that there's some settings
in the settings.system class
that either are read-only,
or have been moved to
settings.global.
Now there's some good reasons
for us doing this.
An example of that is airplane
mode, the toggling of an
airplane mode.
Android 4.2 now has multi-user
capabilities.
So you can have multiple
users on your Nexus 7
or your Nexus 10.
And so if you share your tablet
with a family member or
a friend, they basically have
their own set of applications
and their own-- and those apps
have their own set of data.
So some of these settings are
now going to affect users
across the system itself.
So they have moved.
Now with those settings, whether
you target API 17 or
not, on devices that are API
17 or higher, those things
will have moved.
So we kind of know [INAUDIBLE]
basically if you are accessing
those settings and trying
to change them.
Your app won't just start
crashing, but it'll basically
have no effect if you tried
to write to one
of these older settings.
So keep that in mind.
[INAUDIBLE]
Android 4.2, some of these
settings have changed.
And you really should follow up
in the documentation as to
which ones.
So we've introduced something
new that we call Daydream.
And Daydream is really neat for
users because it's like an
interactive screensaver that
automatically kicks in when
the user has put their device
in a dock, or the device is
idling on a charger.
And the reason that it's really
nice is that it's
another way for you to engage
with your users.
It's another bit of
interactivity that you can add
for your app that drives
users to your content.
So we've obviously got your
typical activities that users
interact with it there.
We've had widgets that allow you
to again have some dynamic
content on users'
home screens.
We've had notifications that
allow you to remind users
that, hey, something important
has happened.
And again, it's a way
to engage them.
Or you've used it for things
like music control so that
users can interact with your
app without having to dive
into your app.
Daydream is another alternative
with an
interactive screensaver mode.
So the picture that we have
there in the top right hand
corner is the gallery
screensaver--
or the picture screensaver.
And so those pictures there,
although they keep coming up
on this particular Daydream,
you as a user can actually
move them around.
So touching the screen doesn't
boot you out of that Daydream.
So to implement Daydream,
you have to look at the
DreamService API.
And in a lot of ways, utilizing
this is similar to
building activities
for your apps.
So you'd call setContentView
after you've
attached to a window.
And then there's a set of
overrides that tell you
basically the state of the
dream-- so onDreamingStarted,
onDreamingStopped.
You can also do other things
like call setInteractive to
say that yes, you have
an interactive dream.
It can also be a passive dream
where just as soon as the user
interacts with it, it gets you
out of the screensaver mode.
And then you can also toggle
things like setScreenBright.
So some of these Daydreams--
the clock one is quite a neat
one because it acts like an
alarm clock.
It shows you the time, but the
screen is actually quite dim
and dull so that for users that
have it on their bedside
tables, you're not illuminating
the whole room
just with a Daydeam.
So you have some control
over that.
Once you've actually started--
you've built your Daydream--
you need to remember to declare
it in your manifest.
So you'd have a service.
And you make sure that you'd
added the intent
filter for it as well.
So there's the Daydreams.
This one I'm really excited
about because it
has a lot of potential.
And it's basically that we've
added a second screen of APIs.
So the Nexus 4 utilizes Miracast
wireless technology
so that you can actually have an
app running on your device
but displaying on a second
screen, like a TV, or other
devices that support the
Miracast standard.
Now the interesting thing about
this is, you're not just
limited to mirroring what
is on your device.
As a developer, you
can write--
use basically the presentation
class and specify user
interfaces on that second screen
that aren't the same as
what you have on your
mobile device.
So you can have this distinction
between a passive
experience and an
interactive one.
So if you're thinking in terms
of games, you might have on
your device, you might have the
heads up display-- let's
say it's a racing game--
you might have the heads up
display or the controls
visible on the screen.
But on the second screen, you
may want to ditch those
because then you can just watch
how the race is going.
And you may not even show
the same perspective.
You might have the driver mode
perspective, or first person
mode on your mobile device.
On a secondary display, it could
be a more cinematic mode
that has the camera outside
of the vehicle.
So anyways, to use this API,
you can use either
DisplayManager or MediaRouter
classes to detect whether the
device has connected to a
secondary display-- whether
there's one available.
And then you would extend the
presentation class and then
you'd construct your class,
your extended class, with
these display objects.
Now one thing to keep in mind--
and this is really
important--
is that more often than not,
the secondary screen will
actually be a different
resolution and a different
size to what your mobile
device is.
So you shouldn't make any
assumptions that your layouts
need to be the same, even
though they will--
if you are doing the
mirroring-type
mode then yeah, sure.
But if you're building custom
displays for the second
screen, you need to use the
resources that are attributed
to that presentation class.
So within your presentation
class, you call getContext and
call getResources.
So that when you load resources
to display--
so let's say drawables
for example--
that it's getting them from the
right folders, whether it
would be XHDPI or HDPI or
even using the [? BP ?]
smallest-width qualifiers.
So you need to keep that in mind
when you're working with
this, that you can have a
different set of resources on
the secondary display compared
to the primary one.
So really awesome stuff there.
I can't wait to see what
comes out of this.
I'm sure this is just the start
of something really big
for second screen apps.
The next one is actually one
of my favorite new features
which are lock screen widgets.
And basically what it means is
that, typically, what we've
had so far on the default
launcher--
another being some third
party lock screen apps
that could do this.
But on the default launcher,
you'd have the time and then
you'd have the slide to unlock
with the circle to go to
camera, or unlock, or
even Google now.
Or you'd have the entry
for your password or
patent and so on.
Well now you can actually have
other widgets than just the
clock there.
And this is not just
with the--
this isn't the default
launcher.
But we've added the
ability for you to
create your own widgets.
By default the devices
will come
with things like calendar--
TONY CHAN: Gmail--
ANKUR KOTWAL: --there's also one
other clock widget which
is actually--
you can see all your
international clocks.
But we can't wait to see what
users will-- how they'll
expand this capability.
So basically, all you need to
do is have a typical app
widget that you've always had.
And you have to add a new
attribute again in the
manifest where you specify
that the category of this
particular widget is also
on the home screen.
So this is an attribute, this
widget category attribute.
And if you don't have the
attribute there, the default
value is home screen
But the new value--
and I mixed this up before-- but
the new value is keyguard,
so that it shows up on
your lock screen.
Tony, was there something
you were saying?
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
I was adding Gmail.
We have a widget for
Gmail as well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Ah, Gmaill--
yes, of course.
I'm not too keen on sharing my
Gmail on my look screen, but
I'm pretty particular
about security.
But I can see it would
definitely be convenient.
So keep in mind as well, by
the way, that when you add
these widgets you want to add
capabilities in those widgets
that are still respecting
the privacy of the user.
From a security point of view,
keep in mind that if somebody
steals a device that's locked by
a password, that the people
that have got hold of the
device, they can't add widgets
to the lock screen without
unlocking the device first.
We've tried to be particular
there.
But you know, app developers,
you show whatever
you want in the view.
So keep that balance in mind.
Now it's important that you
specify an initial layout.
And you do it again with
an attribute called
initialKeyguardLayout.
And basically, this is the
initial layout that's shown.
And then you can update that
layout as you go through.
So those are lockscreen
widgets.
[INAUDIBLE] super useful.
We also added multi-user
support.
Yeah.
Finally.
So that means now we can do
things like tablet sharing
between family members
or friends.
And as an app developer, you
actually don't need to do
anything special to have your
apps work in multi-user mode.
There are exceptions.
If you've been bending the rules
and hard-coding pods in
your apps like /sdcard and
making assumptions around what
directories to store data in,
you're potentially adding
security holes.
Because you could be writing now
data for user 1 in an area
that's globally visible,
even by user 2.
So we've always had a set of
methods that gave you access
to specific storage
directories.
If you weren't using them
before, please update your
apps to use them now.
Because it can be seen as a
potential security risk.
So on internal storage, you've
got things like getFilesDir,
getCacheDir, and
openFileOutput.
But external storage, and often
this is a really cool
part of it, is the
getExternalFilesDir and
getExternalStora
gePublicDirectory.
So yeah-- this is again, it's
totally seamless otherwise to
developers.
But, that's on the assumption
that you've been doing the
right thing.
So it's worth auditing your
code if you're unsure what
you've done here.
And of course, with every
platform release, we have lots
and lots of other additions.
So things that we've
added-- right to
left support in views.
For text rendering, in your
application, you have to add
an attribute called
supportRtl.
And then you have to go
on to find your views
accordingly as well.
We've also added something that
developers been asking
for for a while, which is
called nested fragments.
So you can now have a fragment
within a fragment.
To nest them, what you
need do is call this
getChildFragmentManager, for
when you're doing your
fragment transaction.
Then you can see there's some
sample code there that shows
you that, when we go to do the
transaction, the begin
transaction is actually called
on getChildFragmentManager.
And we are adding the
video fragment
to an existing fragment.
Renderscript has also seen
some improvements--
things like script groups,
script intrinsics, and
Filterscript.
So grouping your bits of your
code in Renderscript, we
basically have continued to
improve the performance and
parallelism of Renderscript
so you get some tremendous
performance out of it.
And we've got some new
capabilities there that will
make it easier for you.
Of course, now that we have a
new platform released, we also
have some great updates to
the developer tools.
So now we have an awesome
improvement to the layout
editor that we previewed
at Google iO.
But basically, as you can see
from the screen shots, we have
this made view open
which which looks
like a tablet layer.
And then we've got a bunch of
small thumbnails on the right.
Those thumbnails are actually
showing previews of that same
layout on how to be reminded
on different sized screens.
And we've obviously got some
profiles there for the Nexus
1, the Nexus S, Galaxy
Nexus, Nexus 7, and
just 10-inch WXJ tablet.
Excuse me.
And as you make changes on your
main editor there, it
will automatically update the
other layouts to show you in
real time what those
changes look like.
So you don't need to toggle
between them.
You can see all of
them at once now.
This is really handy
for where you're
targeting multiple layouts.
And I hope by now, developers,
that you are targeting
multiple layouts.
Because in this day and age, if
you're not doing tablet and
phone layouts, these are
opportunities that you're
missing out on.
Of course, we've added
more Lint rules.
Lint is probably my favorite
feature in
the Android SDK tools.
It finds all sorts of potential
runtime issues, but
it finds them at compile time.
So it's really, really useful.
We've added a bunch of
new rules there.
And we've also continued to
increase the number of
templates--
app templates-- that we
have in the SDK tools.
So you're not having to write
as much of that boilerplate
code as you had to
in the past.
We've added a new UI Automator
Test Framework.
Basically we have a viewer that
allows you to scan and
analyze your apps
user interface.
And then there's this UI
Automator Java library that
has a set of APIs that
allow you to
create functional tests.
Finally, we now have something
that, again, developers have
been asking for for ages,
which is a one-click SDK
install package.
So you can go and download
this one package.
And it includes the development
environment as
well as ADT-- the Android
developer tools--
the SDK tools, as well as an
emulator image, and the APIs
for the latest version
of Android, which
of course is 4.2.
The Android virtual device
creation dialogue has also
been given a new
lick of paint.
It's a lot nicer to use now.
So for those of you that have
gone and created different
combinations of AVDs to try out
different layouts and so
on, this is a lot nicer.
So you can see right off the
bat there that we've added
things like you being able to
specify cameras there, turning
on GPU acceleration just with
that Host GPU check box.
It's a lot nicer,
a lot easier.
One of the things that we've had
developers come back to us
and say, hey, I've
got a 4.2 device.
But I can't find developer
options
any more in my settings.
What we're going to be doing, is
we're publishing an app on
Google Play that enables those
developer options.
But basically, you can get past
it by going into About
Tablet or About Phone if
you're on a phone--
and tapping the build number.
I think the magic number
of times you need
to tap it is seven.
But after you do it two or
three times, it tells you
things like, you are now four
steps away, three steps, two
steps, and so on.
And then it magically appears.
This screen shot was
put together
by someone on Google+--
[? Morrits Tolksdorf ?].
So thanks for that.
So that is really just a quick
rundown on all the new
capabilities of the Android
4.2 platform.
We're really excited, because I
think there's some great new
capabilities here that
developers can really take
advantage to provide unique
and compelling user
experiences.
But before we go to Q&A, we
should talk about something
that we announced over
a month ago.
It was called ADL+ experiments,
when we talked
about the connectivity APIs.
And we'd asked a bunch
of developers--
well all of you actually--
to build us something cool to
show us, utilizing those APIs.
And then we we're going
to discuss it in a
future episode of ADL+.
Well unfortunately, we're going
to call that a failed
experiment.
We didn't get too much interest
from developers.
So we're looking at ways on how
we can move forward with
that program.
We do think that there's some
real advantages there.
But we probably need a
different approach.
So on that note, let's move
to Q&A. We've got a set of
moderator questions.
I'll just see who's live.
We've got Linden
and Marco live.
So if you guys have questions,
feel free to ask us now.
And after that we will
go to moderator.
So Linden has pasted some
questions in the chat.
Does the support
lib provide the
getChildFragment manager method?
I don't know if it's
specifically
that method, Linden.
But we've actually added support
for nested fragments
in the support library,
revision 11.
I think you might need to--
I'm not sure whether it's called
exactly the same thing.
You might have the word
"support" in there somewhere.
I'll have to just look
it up for you.
LINDEN: Yeah.
That's cool.
Oh I can talk now as well.
I un-muted.
Are there any quirks
with that?
Any known oddities, I
suppose, that you
guys have seen already?
Or is it pretty
straightforward and pretty robust?
ANKUR KOTWAL: It's pretty
straightforward, pretty robust.
The only--
I wouldn't call this a quirk--
the only gotcha that you need to
be aware of-- and it's the
same one that's always
been there--
is that you don't want to be
mixing support fragments and
native fragments.
So in your app, if you're using
fragments, you either
use support fragments throughout
or you use native
fragments throughout.
They are different classes.
So they don't just-- you can't
just interchange them and
expect them to work.
LINDEN: Awesome.
Tony, sorry mate.
Were you looking to add
something to that?
TONY CHAN: No, no.
It's fine.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All
right, Marco.
Did you have any questions
for us?
MARCO: Yeah.
I asked if there was any
best practices for
using nested fragments.
I wanted to see if they're any
gotchas or anything that we
should be looking out for?
Like I noticed that when I had
fragments in a view pager that
were hosted by another fragment,
I could no longer
set retaining stints on
the child fragments.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You could
no longer--
OK.
I'm not familiar with
that actually.
Because it such a new API, I
must admit I haven't had a
chance to play with the
nested fragments
in the support library.
So I don't actually know the
answer for this one off the
top of my head.
Tony?
TONY CHAN: So--
me neither.
But I think we are planning--
we were actually just
talking about is.
We will have a separate
ADL+ session, actually
presentations, focusing on
nested fragments, So we will
get some of our teammates'
feedback and best practice.
And we will present that
in a more formal
session in the future.
MARCO: Awesome.
Sounds good.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sorry.
Did you have a follow up?
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
Let's take a look at some of
the questions asked on the
moderator maybe.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
I'll just share the window.
OK
TONY CHAN: So the first one is
Android 2.x supports IPSec VPN
using PSK--
PAP/MS-CHAP.
Is But it's not in
4.x anymore.
Why?
Is it removed?
Or is it possible to implement
a VPN client support that--
So, in terms of API, I don't
think we have PAP and
CHAP in full API.
But last I checked in 4.0, we
still have PSK, but not for
PAP and CHAP configurations.
So we need to check with the
team, see whether we moved
these [INAUDIBLE]
for [INAUDIBLE] reason
or some other reason.
So I guess next week we
can find the answer
get back from them.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
Is it possible to use
ViewPager.PageTransformer with
Jake Wharton's NineOldAndroids
library to make the animations
on page views backward
compatible to OS 2.1?
So it seems--
Marco, is this the
same-- is it you?
Or is this a different Marco?
MARCO: No.
It's me.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I personally
have not used Jake's
NineOldAndroids library.
So I'm personally not sure about
the compatibility there.
I suspect he'll probably
know because the
ViewPager.PageTransformer
has been around
for a while, right?
Tony, is there anything you
wanted to add to that?
TONY CHAN: Not with
the ViewPager.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
So we're not sure, Marco.
I suspect, try asking Jake.
We'll try and follow up
in a future episode.
But we don't know right now.
MARCO: OK.
ANKUR KOTWAL: What feature of
Android 4.2 or 3.x, is the
best for making static pages not
more than five to seven?
I do not want animation.
The static pages contains
text of eternal truth.
OK.
That's interesting.
I may change the font style,
but not the text content.
So I think this person is just
basically saying that they've
got five to seven
pages of text.
They don't want to animate
from there.
So I'm guessing maybe they've
got like a Next button and it
just refreshes the screen.
Is that your understanding
of this question, Tony?
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: There's lots
of ways you can do this.
If you're just using a single
text view, you can just listen
to the button click for whatever
next, or if you've
got a swipe gesture, and
just update the text
in your text views.
Alternatively, you can change
the views that you show.
So you may not want to
reuse the text view
for whatever reason.
And you may have a different
set of text views.
So you can just hide
the existing
ones, show these ones.
You could probably go from
activity to activity and say
that you explicitly don't want
an activity animation.
So there's lots of
ways to do this.
The animations are there to
give a more pleasant user
experience.
But if you are after something
that's quite enough frills and
you just want to change
values, lots of
different ways to do it.
All right.
This was Marco's question around
the best practices when
nesting fragments within
fragments.
We're going to get
back to that.
We'll talk about nested
fragments in the future, in an
upcoming episode.
There's a link here to
action quick clock.
Do you know--
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
The quick clock we're referring
to here is in 4.2.
If you drag the notification
tray down and it's really
great on top.
It's really a o'clock
we're talking to.
So understand Dex mentioned is
not triggering the intent.
But I just actually tried it
myself with an intent and it
actually launched my application
properly.
So it's really that clock.
When you drag down the
notification tray, it's really
the one on top.
So that's the one we were
referring to before.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
So, Dex, I don't know
if you're watching.
But if you still can't
get it to work,
obviously Tony has a solution.
So feel free to just reach
out to Tony afterwards.
And maybe there's something in
your code or your solution
that doesn't match this.
When does Android start
supporting the
Bluetooth IMAP profile?
I think the great Jellybean
is missing it.
So we typically don't
talk about--
we're not able to talk
about features that--
when we're bringing features
to the platform.
So the answer is really,
we don't know.
But it's something that we can
take back to our engineering
team to say, hey, developers
are asking for it.
Any highlights on the support
package revision 11?
So yes.
And let me just share that
particular window with you.
So if you just do a Google
search for Android Support
Library, this is the first
hit you'll get.
Support package revision 11--
we've got a set of new
capabilities.
I already mentioned the
nested fragments.
There's some classes there for
the ViewPager and some
accessibility improvements
as well.
So here's the full
list of them.
And you can go through them in
detail for the ones that are
relevant to your app.
OK.
Let's go back to
the questions.
Last one.
Tony, another VPN one?
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
It points to a link.
So since VPN API is available
in 4.0, can this API help
making connections?
Or it is not supporting
this API also?
So I look at the questions,
and also the APIs.
The API itself is actually
helping for preparing VPN
connections.
I think it actually does
what phone was asking.
If not, ping me and we can
look into this further.
I think that 4.0 VPI
does what you ask.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
Great.
Well, that's the full list
of questions for today.
People that are watching live,
if you have any more
questions, please post them
either in the thread.
Or if you're live--
Linden, Marco--
if you've got any other
questions, now's your chance.
LINDEN: Yeah.
I've got something.
I'm working on something at
the moment that's the old
credit card swipe view.
Now I'd made something similar
earlier this year before I
knew that Gallery
was deprecated.
And so I was going to go grab
that code and tweak it a bit.
And then saw, obviously,
Gallery's deprecated.
So I'm using the ViewPager
within a ViewPager at the
moment, because the
outer [? UI ?]
is in a ViewPager so you can
swipe the whole pages across.
That's OK, because I can push
on the motion onto the inner
ViewPager without a problem.
But I'm also using that set
child clipping false trick to
show the neighboring items
in that ViewPager.
Mark, my nephew, has got
a post about it.
There's a bunch of people that
have done a bit of work about
it But I'm finding it's
really nasty.
Because you end up with a
ViewPager that's really not
the full width of the screen.
And when you go to the end--
when you motion to the end--
you're getting that glow pop
up, not on the edge of the
screen, but halfway in.
There's also some artifacts
in there.
If you hold your finger down
slowly do motions--
I'm just wondering, do you know
if there's a better trick
out there that no one's
been talking about?
ANKUR KOTWAL: So let me just
get a better understanding.
Because this concept of putting
a ViewPager within a
ViewPager seems like it could
be quite confusing to users.
Because if you're using--
in the outer ViewPager, you're
using swipes to swipe through
the outer ViewPager.
Then you suddenly end up on a
specific page, off that outer
ViewPager, that's now consuming
those swipes.
You've kind of broken the
swipe navigation.
LINDEN: Yeah.
I'm aware of that.
And I've trialed it.
Really, I think that it
actually tilts the
[? opposite. ?]
Because they are all actually
hinting by having the main
navigation in a ViewPager, and
then you hit a page and
someone accidentally swipes on
this inner ViewPager, they've
just found out, really
obviously, that that is its
own little motion element.
So in a way, that outer swiping
hints to swiping anyway.
And there's plenty of other room
to swipe to get to the
other pages.
There's tabs as well, so
they can click on it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: My personal
preference would be, that you
wouldn't want to override
the horizontal swipes.
And Marco said, it's a
conflict of swipes.
And I agree with that.
You probably wouldn't want to
override that swiping behavior
from the outer ViewPager to
suddenly an inner one.
Other things you could consider,
for that inner
ViewPager that you have now,
could that, instead of swiping
horizontally, be a
vertical swipe?
So horizontally is taking
you across categories.
And vertically is the
one that-- you said
credit cards, right?
So if you've got a set of cards,
instead of having them
next to one another, you have
them vertically sorted?
Would that be something
that might be useful?
LINDEN: That would sort of work
until I go and chuck it
in a scroll view or something
like that.
I'm taking an app that's
on iOS and it
has that swipe mechanism.
But it's going from a Dashboard
into each section.
And I'm trying flatten the whole
navigation for Android
to make it a lot quicker to get
into the app, a lot more
straightforward.
And just sort of cutting the
crap, so to speak, which is a
long Australian past time.
Yeah.
It seems to be working.
I don't think the problem that
I'm seeing is really to do
with the mix up of
motion itself.
It's more I think that the
ViewPager is designed to take
up the full width of the page.
And because of that, the stuff
that you could do with
Gallery, in terms of having
multiple items seen side by
side next to the one that is
currently selected, I'm not
really seeing a drop in
replacement with ViewPager for
that kind of functionality.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
I haven't had to resort to
that clicking trick that
you've mentioned.
The one thing I'd ask
is, could you just
try this for me?
And I just don't know if there's
a conflict there.
Could you try having that inner
ViewPager not be nested
inside another ViewPager, and
just see if those same
artifacts, whether you're
still seeing them?
I just don't know whether--
because you've got a ViewPager
within a ViewPager, I don't
know if there's issues coming
from that or the fact that
you're using this clipping
feature.
LINDEN: Yeah.
I'll give it a shot breaking
it down and might even jot
some code out somewhere so if
you get a chance, have a look.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sure.
LINDEN: Awesome.
MARCO: It just seems that like
from a Android usability point
of view, your users might
not be expecting that.
The way that you're using a
ViewPager within a ViewPager,
I don't think I've seen it in
other apps at the moment.
LINDEN: Yeah.
I was very cautious
and aware of that.
And so I trialed it.
And to be honest, my finding is
that actually it hints more
that that ViewPager takes
motion, because people are
already doing motion
across the screen.
Otherwise, you'd have a static
page that you're not
doing motion on.
And you'd need to have some kind
of hint like, hey, you
can swipe across this.
But if they're swiping across
things and then suddenly an
inner swiper moves by itself
and the whole page doesn't,
it's actually--
I reckon honestly--
it's working a bit
better that way.
But we'll see what happens.
The artifacts I don't like
so I've got to find a
solution for that.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Actually,
if you could also--
if you're going to reach out to
me with some code, if you
could just take some screenshots
or a small video
or something just to
show the artifacts.
Or send an APK.
If it's credit card related
you might not be able
to send me an APK.
LINDEN: It's cards.
I'm just saying the credit card
thing because that's the
sort of typical widget that
people are saying--
Google Wallet that kind of stuff
has that kind of swipe
card thing.
It's a pretty common thing
in mobiles these days.
But just the dropping
the gallery,
for whatever reasons--
it's got its own problems--
but really it was able to
provide that functionality
better [INAUDIBLE].
ANKUR KOTWAL: And the only
other thing I'll say--
and I don't want to dwell
on it too much but--
because you've got this
nesting within a--
alternatives to that is that
your top level ViewPager could
instead be a spinner on the
action bar, which obviously
acts as a drop down.
Or the sliding drawer really
works well, because you can
see all of the categories that
have supporting icons as well.
You could still have the swiping
left to right for the
card view, but navigating across
categories could be
done by a spinner or
sliding drawer.
LINDEN: OK.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
Cool.
Thanks for that.
I don't see any more questions
on the thread.
All right.
Well, thanks for joining.
And hope it was informative.
We'll catch you guys
next time.
MARCO: Thank you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: See you later.